[Music]
this 21st century elixir promises to
turn the wooliest wall flower into a
bull fighting base jumping
break dancing extremophile
but what's really inside a can of red
bull
primarily sugar
sucrose and glucose are the backbone of
any soft drink
so that's pretty sweet but sugar doesn't
give you wings
caffeine does
it stimulates your central nervous
system and metabolism which sharpens
your concentration and reaction time and
makes you feel on top of the world
next up is taurine an organic acid found
in animal tissue german scientists
discovered the stuff in oxfiel in 1827
naming it for the latin taurus or bull
the synthetic taurine found in a single
red bull can have wide-ranging effects
some studies show it can be a mood
stabilizer even an antioxidant but the
rest of this stuff
health authorities don't think
glucoronalactone does any harm
but it's not proven to do any good
either
some users claim it fights fatigue and
increases well-being but that could be
bull too
niacin can raise your good cholesterol
and sodium citrate can boost athletic
performance but red bull doesn't have
enough of either to have much effect
then there's anesthetic a carbohydrate
found in muscle
in quantity
this meat sugar as it's sometimes called
reduces depression panic attacks
agoraphobia and ocd to get those effects
from red bull you'd need to drink about
360 cans a day so if you need a quick
lift what's inside a red bull might help
but don't expect magic especially if you
mix it with vodka
[Music]
feeling wired yet subscribe